[Music]
and if watch's very intense there's an
intensity I think it's that's hard to to
capture in these films because you've
seen so many police movies but this one
does I was watching it late at night and
then couldn't sleep afterwards it's so
it's got that kind of yeah thank you so
I was cranky with my kids the next day
and now my wife is leaving me but that's
another story
but to prepare for this you you did the
thing I've heard of actors doing this
you rode with the LAPD we spent five
months on the streets with LAPD two or
three times LAPD Sheriff's Department
and Englewood PD you know two or three
times a week like 4:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m.
in the morning we did probably over 50
ride-alongs with with law enforcement
unless we're where are you riding in the
car are you in the front seat are you in
the back seat where where they put the
criminals yes we're in the back seat
right there's usually only two seats in
the front of the car yeah and that's
left for the officers so we were in the
boughs dare you speak to me this way I
know you think I should guide you along
I know you think you're in great shape
but you haven't felt what Sun
- sigh you were trying me that's all did
it feel like pudding in there if you
like someone I put frozen yogurt in the
sleeve of the shoe just don't try and
get that close to me again well I'm
gonna respect the healing halls fear
it's fun of lingonberries
so you're riding with these guys did you
did they ever make any arrests while you
were in the car and then they're getting
arrested and it's 5:00 in the morning
and Jake Gyllenhaal gets out of the
batter like sorry guys we need the back
see you later
no yeah we went through a lot we went
through a lot with the police officers I
mean we witnessed a lot of things I mean
the very first ride-along I was on there
was someone was murdered which was which
was a very tough thing to see and then
night you know a lot of other things
along the way for five months on the
streets with you know police officers in
the southeast side of Los Angeles you're
gonna see a lot of things and I'm magic
goes without saying you come away with a
new respect for these people what
they're up against and what it's like to
be living like that every day - I would
say it's beyond respect yeah I mean to
be a first responder in situations and
to have to deal with some of the things
that they do with you know and also on
the opposite side I think you know I see
it's a brotherhood you know and for us
the biggest thing in the movie was that
the stuff that goes on inside the car
before they actually respond to a call
is great stuff it's full of you know
they're always joking around and then as
soon as a call comes in you know they're
focused on the job at hand but the best
stuff is inside the car you know with
the two best friends essentially when
you're riding in a car with them there
are some very funny moments in the in
the movie that are natural they're real
it's not like they're not gags it's they
come up there they're character driven
but there's a great scene where you were
- your wedding your character's wedding
and your break dancing yes I'm you do a
complete break dance routine yes I am
how do you feel about your have you you
look at it now and feeling good about
your break dance routine I expected a
bigger response from that one yes I do
great day
I've never seen an audience applaud as
they're filing out
actually what happens when I breakdance
it's a really fun scene but it looked
like you guys really worked out a good
routine you know we did yeah me and Anna
Kendrick yeah we get married in the
movie place your watch and she is an
incredible dancer I can say and so I
just was following her lead but there's
one moment in the dance where I actually
have to do it all myself and I do do a
little spin move on the floor there is a
lot of very nice like you say you've
created a nice environment in the police
car you feel that these are real police
officers who like each other they're
real people they know each other and we
have a clip here the funny moment I
believe I don't know if this is a moment
from the car from the police station
this isn't in the car but this in the
police station we're filling out
paperwork which my character says is but
the lifeblood of the organization which
a lot of people don't you know in movies
you always see the action you see what's
going on but in this movie at times you
get to see what a real police officer
has to deal with and most of the time
there's a lot of paperwork and a great
deal of boredom so yeah this is what
happens in a little-little event that
happens in the in the you know in the
office end of watch let's take a look
this clip yeah I heard he took a shot at
you you okay yeah I'm fine good he's
good
Liberace's ake a look like Liberace's
okay mm-hmm keep up your word guys I
really appreciate it
carry on thank you yuugi mixer tonight
in van Hauser evening sir why are you
getting nervous women wanna men want to
be a man's just yeah I know but you want
him dude I'm not gay but I go down on
him if you ask sometimes I don't know
when you're kidding
you're kidding I'm not kidding I got to
know when you're kidding
[Applause]